معنا عبر الهاتف فارس النور مستشار الفريق
محمد حمدان دقلو حميدتي اهلا بك معنا سيد
فارس سيد فارس ان كنت تستمع منذ قليل كان
معنا المتحدثه وناطق الرسمي باسم الخارجيه
السودانيه وبحسب تصريحاته هو يقول بانكم
تعطلون سير القوافل برا
لاجلاء الرعايه ما ردكم على هذا التصريح
ان هذا الامر غير صحيح وان الخروقات التي
تاتي دائما تاتي من الطرف الاخر والان انت
لاحظتي في كلامه هو يرفض كيف هو كانه
يتوهم انه يريد ان يقضي على التمرد كما
قال وبالتالي هو الذي يعني يشعر انه يريد
ان لا يريد هدنه بل يريد ان يقضي على
التمرد فبالتالي هو الطرف الذي يقترح وهو
الطرف الذي لا يلتزم بالهده نحن لمن نلتزم
بالهدنه اختي الكريمه نلتزم بها من دواعي
فقط التزمنا بها من اجل التخفيف على ان
شعبنا في في الاول من اجل فرحه العيد ومن
اجل اجلاء الرعايه الاجانب ولكن
على الارض نحن متقدمون نحن نحتل مواقع
استراتيجيه الان كل يوم نحن في تقدم عندما
نلتزم نلتزم صدقا وهو عندما ينتدمون
يلتزمون مناوره
وكذبا واخرها قبل ساعات كيف تقطف مدنيين
بالطيارات يعني يعني هذه في حيات سكنيه
شعبيه حتى لو كان
اخر موجود في هذه لا يمكن ان يعني
تخطفها جريمه دوليه جيده
نحن متقدمون
نحن نفترض للشريكه الذي نعمل معه الخدمه
يعني
الشريك الامامي تتحدث سيد فارس من الشريك
سيد فارس قلت بانه هناك شريك تتواصلون معه
لمحاوله تثبيت هدنه هذا ما فهمت حضرتك
الذي
للهدله لذلك لابد ان يكون الاتفاق لوقف
اطلاق النار اولا
وضحت هذه النقطه في مقابل كل هذا حدثتني
منذ قليل قلت بانكم تؤمنون كذلك سير
القوافل لاجلاء الرعايه ما القوافل ما
الدول التي ساهمتم مثلا في تامين خروجها
من السودان
الدول التي تواصلت معنا وكانت في مناطق
نقود منها الفرنسيه والايطاليه والنيجر
وكل الدول
المحتلين
[موسيقى]
المستشفيات عشان يقدروا يتحركوا للتمويل
عشان يقدروا
يعني
سيدفرس هل صحيح بانكم حاولتم التشويش على
عمليه اجلاء بعض القوافل انطلاقا مش بعض
القوافل اتحدث عن
يعني استهدفتهم بعض المطارات التي كانت
تستعد لاجلاء بعض الرعايه يقين بان الدعم
السريع حاول التشويش على بعض هذه العمليات
ما حقيقه هذا الموضوع
اذا كان المتكلم مجنون والمستمعه لا يمكن
ان يكون المتكلم مجن
في اي معركه نريد ان نكتب نكسب المجتمع
الدولي
بخلينا
نتعرض لمجتمع الدولي شنو يعني الا اذا كنا
نريد ان ننتحر نحن نعتقد اننا مع المجتمع
الدولي مع كل دعاه الديمقراطيه في العالم
نخوض معركه
حلفائنا اثنين نحن التزمنا وهذا التزام
صادق التزام حقيقي فلذلك هذا
رفع
وسوف سوف تخرج في وقتها المناسب لكل
الاحداث التي نحن ساعد
ناه في الوقت المناسب لم افهم سيد فارس
لماذا الوقت المناسب لان الحديث صار كثير
واخذ حجم كبير فيما يخص تهديدكم لبعض
المطارات
فعلا صور موجوده ولكن هذا ليس يعني لا
اعتقد ان هذه المشكله
الان هي نحن المجتمع الدولي في تحالف
سياسي كبير من اجل الديمقراطيه التي يدعو
لها الجميع من مواثيق حبوب الانسان حريه
يا سيدتي نحن اذا قلنا قبل المعركه وقبل
القدر نحن كنا وافقنا على ان نسلم السلطه
والحكومه المدنيه
ان اعمل الحاجه دي مع الثلاثه يوم هل نحن
كنا سكارى وصحينه ولا ماذا حدث الحدث انه
هنالك
تعتمد
مشكله لما المدنيين اتفقوا والموضوع مشى
هو
عصورا لذلك اراد ان يفجر الاوضاع سيد فارس
ساعود معك لهذه النقطه ولنقطه المبادرات
تعلم حضرتك بان هناك مبادرات وهناك محاوله
للوصفات مختلفه افريقيه اقليميه ولكن اسمح
لي ان اعود لتفصيل اخر كان ورد في بيانات
كنا طلعنا عليها
مفادها بان الدعم السريع يستخدم المباني
السكنيه للاحتماء بها ويستخدم المدنيين
كضروع بشريه
يا سيدتي يا سيدتي لا يمكن للدعم السريع
ان يقوم بذلك نحن اقول لك مرارا وتكرارا
نحن الان نحن متقدمون في المعركه ونقبل
الهدى من اي شعبنا نقبل الهدنه من اجل
شعبا ولكن الذي يحدث ان هنالك طرف ثالث
يرتدي ملابس الدعم السريع ويريد ان يشويه
صورتنا لذلك هو
يعني يمشي للمناطق السكنيه ويضربها وكما
قلت لك
المدنيين بالطيارات
سيد فارس صحيح ولكن سيد فارس نقطه ملفته
ماتت تفضل بالاشاره لها تقول حضرتك بان
هناك بعض المندسين الذين يرتدون ملابس
تشبه ملابس دعم السريع او هي نفسها تقريبا
وهم من يحتمون بالمدنيين يحاولون التشويش
على
حضوركم في مختلف هذه المناطق حدثنا اكثر
عن هذه المعلومات
يا سيدتي نحن منذ فرض الاحتصام هنالك
تناريست واحد فنرست واحد هو الذي يعني
يقوم
بهذه التمثيليه انه
يعتمد على التراتبيه في اوامر في الجيش
الجيش يعتمد على على
التراتبيه في الامر لذلك فيفضل الاعت
صام الذين موجودين في
القياده العليا للجيش هم من اعطوا الاوامر
لجنود ففضل الاعتصام الان نفس السيناريو
يتكرر في القياده وارادوا ان يقودوا الناس
الى المحرقه والديكتاتوريه اعطوا الاوامر
وغدروا الدعم السريع ووضعوا
حتى امام المعركه وعملوا حرب نفسيه كبيره
جدا عشان الناس ما تقدر ترجع نقول انه نحن
كررنا كثير يا سيدتي نحن قبل ثلاثه يوم
نحن النقطه المهمه انه نحن ما طارحين
نفسنا بديل للقوات المسلحه نحن كنا
بنتفاوض معاهم انه نحن حدا مع بعض دايرين
نكون ليش قومي واحد يحمل دستور وجيش قومي
واحد يقدر يحمي البلد يحمي الحكومه
المدنيه ويحمل تحول الديمقراطي بعد ثلاثه
يوم نبقى نحن الاعداء ونحن اللي بنعمل هذا
طرف ثالث هذا الامر يدمر هذه النقطه ولكن
سيد فارس قلت منذ قليل بان هناك ما وصفتهم
بالشرفاء داخل الجيش السوداني اعترفت بان
هناك
شخصيات قادره ان تتفاعلوا تتواصلوا معها
هي شخصيه مقبوله لدى الدعم السريع فالسؤال
هنا هل تتواصلون مع بعض الاشخاص المعروفين
بانتسابهم للجيش
القوات المسلحه شرفاء حتى انهم لا يحتاجون
للتواصل مع
للاسف نحن لما النظام السابق اسقطنا من
الذراع المدني الحكومه ولم نضبط الزراعه
العسكري الموجود داخل الجيش هؤلاء هم
الذين سيطروا على الجيش ولكن هنالك شرفاء
داخل القوات المسلحه والان
يبقى انضم لل
دعمه فهم فره وخل
القياده اصلا لانهم رافضين لهذا الامر فيا
سيدتي
نحن من ليه لانه
نحن الجنود هذه دماء عزيزه وغاليه علينا
جدا مما اخواننا امام من كنا نتمنى ان
نبني معهم جيشا قوميا واحد يحمي مستقبل
السودان
ماذا تطلبون قلت نطلب
نطلب منهم ان يحكموا عقولهم
يستطيعوا هم ان يزحوا هذه القله ويستطيع
ان يكونوا القياده التي تليق بالجيش
السودان التي تريد ان تذهب بالبلاد الى
التحول
اسمح لي سيد فارس ان اختم معك بموضوع
الوساطه تعلم حضرتك بان هناك مبادرات
عديده من من بين هذه المبادرات او هذه
الوساطه الاقرب الاكيد بانكم اطلعتم على
تفاصيل بعض هذه الوصفات او المبادرات او
الكلام الذي وصلكم من بعض الاطراف من
الاقرب من الجهه الاقرب للدعم السريع
والقادره ان تطرح وسط حقيقيه
الجهه الاغربيه
الجهه وكلنا نحن لدينا
علاقات المجتمع الدولي مع المجتمع
الاوروبي مع المحيط الاقليمي كل هؤلاء
وهم كانوا يرعوا
الاتفاق الاول
ولكن افتكر الان الاشكال الكبير هو مدى
الشريك الذي سوف ندير معه التفاوض نحن
عشان السودان لازم الاول يكون
في وقت النار يا سيدي هذه ما هو الشرط
الذي بعده نستطيع ان ننتقل اعتقد اصدقاء
السودان في المجتمع الدولي هم يريدون خيرا
للسودان وهم سوف يدعون الى النصل الى
الاهداف التي نحن يعني وضعها الشعب
السوداني
ونريد وقف اطلاق نار حقيقي مش كلام
الليله انت تقول لي كلام بعد يعني يعني
البرهان اصبح انت لا تدري تدري تصريحاته
يعني هل اذا سالتيني ما رايك
في تصري سؤال ولا بعده هذا رجل متلون هذه
قياده هذا كذب نحن مستعدون اذا هنالك شريك
حقيقي نعمل معه وقت لاطلاق نار حقيبه ولا
حتى فكره حضرتك اود شكرك جزيلا شكر على كل
ما تفضلت به من توضيحات من الخرطوم عبر
الهاتف فارس النور مستشار الفريق محمد
حمدان شكرا لك
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات